the pin pinning and winning
could be the end of the game that would
be brutal the black rook coming down
pinning and if the white knight takes
this rook you actually win both of the
black both of the white knights now in
one swoop you play queen takes knight
check and he's done it he's about to win
both white knights and he's going to
emerge with an extra bishop for free
and with the attack so yeah this one is
going to be game over any moment
harry krishna about to be a clear piece
up
is there any maybe any
queen and the queen can come and give a
check so eric has tried that okay the
king moves away
you can even block it with a bishop yeah
like you say i mean you're just moving
the king if you're short time is
probably the move to play uh if you
can't calculate blocking with a bishop
but this bishop block is very effective
if the white knight takes this bishop
then queen uh okay queen takes knight
check and we're about to see a result
this will end in checkmate uh the white
king is not going to escape from this
attack it's very nice